here are this week's top movies western  the Kings montañés shop in London after  their headquarters is destroyed British  spies team up with their American  counterparts in Kingsman the Golden  Circle I'm taking a solemn oath to form  the secret ninja force in the lego  ninjago movie six teenaged ninjas must  come of age while defending their Island  home dad  the Lloyd that's right in battle of the  sexes tennis great Billie Jean King  takes on male chauvinist pig Bobby Riggs  in a match for the ages see what's hot  in theaters with this week's fan tissa  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]